we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a caller who seems to think trump
is going to prison
hey david jeff from oregon calling the
with a little comment on your show
tonight
as always enjoy your show but you were
stating that
there's no way donald trump would ever
go to jail
and if we actually have a free and fair
election and
joe biden is elected there's only three
ways that
that uh trump never goes to jail okay
one
the intro of the president pence
uh pardons him two
biden pulls and obama and goes oh we're
looking forward we're not looking back
for three during all the legal wrangling
he actually passed away
those are the only three ways that
donald trump does not go to jail for
all the crimes he committed before his
presidency during the campaign
and during his presidency i just
respectfully disagree the the united
states
is not the type of country where
former presidents go to prison and i'm
not arguing that trump has not done
things that would put
a normal person in prison that is not my
argument my argument is merely
trump is not going to prison that that's
my prediction
maybe i'll be wrong we've got a great
bonus show for you today don't miss it
grab a membership
join pacman.com you will be provided
instant access to the bonus show